Washing your hands may be the best way to
keep from getting sick, but in some ways,
DIRT does a body good.
We’ve all been taught that dirt is bad for
us.
In my Grandmother’s house “Cleanliness
was next to Godliness” and everything was
scrubbed clean and disinfected, but now with
new research on the superpowers of the microbiome
it may be time to rethink our relationship
with filth.
You may think dirt and soil are interchangeable,
(they are both a grainy collection of minerals,
oils, water, and organic matter.)
BUT soil stays in your backyard while dirt
is what follows you back into your house.
BOTH have microbes.
Germ theory tells us that these microbes can
infect our bodies and make us sick, but we
are starting to understand that in our haste
to eliminate and defend against disease we
may have unintentionally “protected” ourselves
against the collaborative relationships we
need most.
Yes, over exposure to some microorganisms
will make us sick, but of the thousands of
species and up to 6lbs (yes POUNDS of bacteria
that are living in and on our bodies RIGHT
NOW some are critical for our health and happiness.
The bacteria that live in our bodies, sometimes
called our microbiome, help us digest food,
respond to pathogens, and may even influence
our moods.
Getting dirty once in a while can help repopulate
“friendly” bacteria that have been killed
off or washed away by our hygiene practices.
Commonly, we’re taught to clean ourselves
thoroughly to prevent illness *but* we could
be killing off too much good bacteria.
Studies show that we need exposure to both
friendly and unfriendly bacteria to maintain
health and a strong immune system.
Some exposure to disease causing pathogens
early in life, helps to build our body’s
defences keeping us healthy as adults.
When our body “fights” a disease, it is
activating immune cells in response to a remembered
disease agent.
The Hygiene Hypothesis suggests that the right
amount of exposure to germs and dirt builds
our body’s library of known diseases, and
teaches our immune system to remember which
microbes, proteins, and viruses are dangerous.
Without this training, our immune system may
become hyperactive, looking for diseases to
fight and it may find innocuous aspects of
our own biology instead.
When the body attacks itself, it can cause
autoimmune disorders such as asthma and Inflammatory
Bowel Disorder.
An example of this was seen in a study of
germ-free mice that had been raised in a sterile
environment.
The mice were compared to normal mice living
in a microbe rich environment.
The germ-free mice were found to have several
immune disorders such as inflammation of the
lungs and colon which resemble human asthma
and colitis.
These conditions were caused by hyperactivity
of a type of immune cell that had been previously
linked to these diseases in both mice and
humans.
Most importantly, the researchers discovered
that exposing the germ-free mice to microbes
when they were babies, led to development
of a regular immune response and proper defense
against disease.
So, playing in the dirt as a kid is good for
you and adults it’s not too late!
Put that hand sanitizer away, go hiking, pet
that dog, explore different environments and
all that good bacteria.
GET MESSY!
Remember, in our haste to make our living
conditions more sterile, we may be making
ourselves sick.
Do you want to build a new website without
getting your hands dirty?
Try Domain.com!
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and have all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot club to dot space,
to dot pizza!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
Hey all, love science in your day?
Make sure you subscribe and check out some
of these microbes living in the driest place
on earth on our sister show, Science in the
Extremes
Fun fact: If you’re craving dirt, you might
be pregnant!
The desire to eat dirt is called geophagy,
and it is commonly observed in children and
pregnant women.
Weird!
Thanks for watching Seeker.